هذه هي المحادثات النووية الإيرانية الجارية
التي رأيناها تتراجع عن
بعض مطالبهم الأولية هنا هي أن
الولايات المتحدة وإيران أقرب إلى اتفاق نووي
مما كانت عليه قبل أسبوع أو أسبوعين ، هل
هي تتحرك بشكل إيجابي
الاتجاه برأيكم نحن بالتأكيد
أقرب اليوم مما كنا عليه
قبل أسبوعين بفضل استعداد إيران
أه للتنازل عن عدد من
القضايا الرئيسية أه وما زلنا نعمل في
طريقنا من خلال هذا فلا تزال هناك
فجوات متبقية بين أه  جميع الأطراف هنا ، لذلك
نحن لسنا هناك حتى الآن ،
سنواصل العمل في هذا الأمر ، لقد قمنا
بالرد على الاتحاد الأوروبي
الذي ينظر إليه الآن من قبل الاتحاد
الأوروبي وإيران ، من
الواضح أننا نأمل في الحصول على نتيجة إيجابية
هنا لأنه لا توجد مشكلة في
الشرق الأوسط ليس من السهل حلها
مع إيران المسلحة نوويًا ، لا يزال الرئيس
يعتقد أن الدبلوماسية والعودة إلى
الصفقة هي أفضل نتيجة ممكنة
وسنواصل العمل على ذلك
خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية  عبرت السفن الحربية للولايات المتحدة
مضيق تايوان أه
إعلان الأسطول السابع ما هي
الرسالة التي كانت هذه السفن ترسل
إلى الصين
رسالة واضحة للغاية
رسالة جيم وهي
أن البحرية الأمريكية والجيش الأمريكي
سوف يبحر ويعمل حيثما
يسمح لنا القانون الدولي بذلك.
عبور مباشر بين
هذين الطرادين تم التخطيط له
منذ فترة طويلة في الواقع منذ حوالي أسبوعين إلى ثلاثة
أسابيع ، لقد قلت علنًا أنه
بينما كان المتحدث بيلوسي على الأرض
في تايوان ، سنقوم
بعبور مضيق تايوان في
الأسبوعين المقبلين هذا  هو أن العبور
يتوافق تمامًا مع سياسة الصين الواحدة
بما يتوافق تمامًا مع رغبتنا في
التأكد من أنه يمكننا الاستمرار في العمل
نحو منطقة المحيط الهادئ الحرة والمفتوحة
وهذا يتوافق مع تلك السياسة